did your biological death the the hudson
guy whatever is a Bill Hudson he had
nothing to do with you your whole life
right not my whole life he was around
when we were very young oh he was it
sort of teetered out you know it was
like that lost interest a little bit
more complex
Kate Hudson opens up about her
biological dad Bill Hudson in a new
interview with Howard Stern there is
always you know there is always the the
inability for me to understand my father
right right I don't understand it but
but I missed out on a lot yeah that must
be painful for her hurt him and he must
have his reasons I forgive him he
considers actor Kurt Russell to be her
father
he and Kate's mom Goldie Hawn have been
together for the past 33 years though
they never married I'd love to see my
parents you know if they wanted to but
it's also just I mean 30-plus years I
kind of did it didn't they they're kind
of doing it right yeah they're there's
nothing could be better than what we
have nothing but somehow marriage means
a lot to people when you have a father
like Kurt you know who's sort of been
there for the hard stuff he's not a
perfect man like no one is but he was
the trust that I got from him in terms
of his dependability was was just
priceless for me back in 1989 et
actually spoke to Kate's biological dad
about his kids back then he spoke of an
ongoing custody battle with Goldie I've
been living with the problem of visiting
my children and seeing them on a regular
basis for nine years now I want to see
my children on my terms and I'd like our
relationship to flourish with my
children I'll I'm my hands are tied